you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at a game from the 2014 Bronstein
Memorial Tournament on the white end by
George abhava he's paired against Boris
Savchenko this is a nice illustration of
minor piece play and how to play a
position out when you are down the
exchange
now this exchange sacrifice as we will
soon see Springs about very early on so
this game begins quite enough d4 by Java
and a London system ish start Bishop f4
not a true London system with the knight
on c3 but ok Queen Bishop on f4 it is
one of the points to converge on c7
while that's now prevented III the time
controls for this game by the way are 90
minutes with a 30 second increment and
we'll see in just a little bit why I'm
drawing some attention to the time
control after g6 white sees this as an
opportunity to throw the H pawn down the
board we don't have H 6 or H 5 here
black ignores that just gets on with
development and so white sees this no it
just follows through H 5 it is and here
we go that's the exchange sacrifice I'm
talking about this is not unexpected
black knew that this was going to happen
and you know this is something you would
see out of a Leningrad Dutch variation
risk exchange sacrifice there are
multiple positive features to note about
this position you have to note these
positive features you can't just look at
the material there's so much more going
on beyond the material imbalance so what
what are these factors what are these
features well for one it's really nice
to have just one pawn island up 7 blacks
is fractured has an isolated pawn but
really it's this absent pun that
captures my attention more than anything
the heart of the kingside structure is
off the board and so what does this mean
well I'm concerned now I would be
concerned about the black king
what's his where will his safe haven be
king side that's certainly very scary
without the Jeep on around soon you
could have a bishop pointing at you
guess where the rook is gonna go are you
gonna go Queen side then you have to
cope with the bishop and the Queen
Knight I know I'm painting the board a
lot but these are important things to
know this isn't a sacrifice that will
then be followed up with more sacrifices
in a quick kill the wind of material or
checkmate this is a positional sacrifice
this is a long-term sacrifice first
things first
well light also has a slight lead and
development and was throwing a punch
so that's defended and at the same time
White has now acquired more information
about this guy guess where he's gonna go
he only has one option now Knight f3
follows
notice how the white pieces find it very
easy to just find good squares
Black has difficulties completing
development
h6 denies the night the g5 square
queenside castle 97 to be expected queen
h2 is threatening and embarrassing
bishop c7 queen is cooked Knight f8 as I
made my first pass through this game
this move certainly caught my attention
why you going backwards isn't f6 the
most natural square in the world what's
the issue with Knight to f6 let's see
Bishop c7 and Knight to a4 aha
dark square weaknesses the Knights ready
to pounce with a devastating attack fork
just winning some material in computers
eyes 1.5 ish so what's the difference
with the move plate in the game well
let's see Bishop c7 is still the move
Queen d7 and now we have Bishop e2 so if
Knight a4 is played here with the knight
on FA instead of f6 this is what black
can do this was the idea with Knight f6
the knight would be able to play to e6
in reply to this move and at least fight
for the dark squares on the Queen side
Bishop e2 in the game the knight shoes
the bishop away Bishop to e5 offering a
dark square Bishop exchange here's
another thing when you're up the
exchange what would you like to have
happen
so as black you're up the exchange what
would you like to do open files create
pawn breaks so that that extra rook you
have can be put to use but how do you do
that
really how do you do that I'm asking you
because I don't know
there isn't a successful pawn break that
I see for team black I don't see it
there's one half-opened file 14 black
one half open file for team white
what is not on Black's mind right now is
oh I have that extra rook well let's
just double up on the G file no it's
where am I going with my queen what am i
doing with my bishop look at this clown
on a8 a lot of problems for team black
to solve b5
I don't know it's difficult to suggest
something for black
this is a super weakening move ready to
kick the night away - yeah I don't know
isn't a four and even better square okay
the king is at least here so launching
pawns towards that side maybe one day
these guys could engage with the pawns
but it's just not going to happen
rook h1 f6 Bishop back Knight to g5 one
of the better moves
and don't ask me to explain why exactly
this is the suggestion but computer
wants to go with h5 and then after
Knight to h4 says run go towards the
Queen side because over here is
apparently too dangerous this is one of
the suggestions by the computer yeah
you're not going to see a human do
something like this what stride is
Knight to g5 black once a knight
exchange White says no thanks you've
weakened c5 and I want to jump there in
one move can't do that and one move but
he's getting there
King sight castles it is Knight to d3
again it's scary wherever the king goes
now to deal with the knight on c5 Bishop
here if you go Queen side King side you
have this stuff scary very difficult to
defend for team black we're at move 18
by the way and this earlier note about
the time control
as I was you know fishing for a game to
review for this video
I saw as comment to one of the games
online again I'm not sure that this is
correct about what I'm about to share
but I saw a comment pointing out that at
this stage in the game
Savchenko had just a few minutes
remaining
again I can't confirm that I don't know
if that is true but let's just say if
that did happen I wouldn't be surprised
the game starts with 90 minutes 17 moves
in for you to have exhausted you know
all but just a few minutes of your time
I could very easily see that this is a
very difficult situation for Team black
and continues to be 93 follows Queen and
5 Bishop f4 ready to get the Jeep on
rolling a 5 again
suggest something for black these Tempe
b5 a6 we're soon gonna see b4 I'm not
quite sure what it really accomplishes
okay maybe one day the bishop gets
deployed here that's that's something I
could see but as far as advance
advancing the queenside pawns to a point
where they could eventually engage with
these guys and create open files that's
just not going to happen
continuing night c5 queen h7 here comes
the Jeep on again I don't know really
what to suggest routine black we need
seven queen g6 it's just a small
advantage in the computer's eyes but the
thing is is that it's just so much
easier there's an advantage in that it's
just easier to play for white
continuing bishop c7 not here to
threaten the pond but to get out of the
f pons way b4 Knight a for d5 Knight b6
this rook doesn't have many options look
at these minor pieces rook a7 throws a
punch now the other rook rook to e8
lending some defense to e5 and now here
comes f4 night to f7 and what to do
the thread on the bishop if you would
like to go ahead pause the video see if
you can spot what Joe bhavas next move
is feel free to pause the video okay in
the game what did Joe bhava play g5 who
cares about the bishop we're opening up
this guy's eyes to hit with a skewer
that happens best in this position is to
take on g5 in the game Knight takes
bishop allowing the bishop to sweep in
Queen f5 and let's see how this one
finishes up a knot Bishop takes rook
instead takes on h6 it's cracking open
the G file rook to e7 capturing on h6
would then allow Bishop takes rook and
now these pieces are ready to storm in
along the H file in the game the rook
gets out of the line of fire pawn takes
Bishop
rook takes pawn
a series of exchanges now chain-reaction
basically black is just reacting to
these moves now and recapture mode
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
and now Bishop to g6 just clearing the
way for the major pieces to enter on h8
and what can you do about it the Queen
is hit the Queen will be getting into h8
at this point just a clearance sacrifice
Queen takes Bishop Queen h8 and after
King to f7 rook f1 in black throws in
the towel what is there to do here if
you move the King make it one the only
other option is to block with the Queen
and that would just lose the Queen and
then the knight and this is completely
gone 14 black so an interesting game to
say the least very nice illustration of
minor piece play playing down the
exchange at a very early point and
really acquiring a position where it was
far easier for white to complete
development and black struggled at an
early point and never really found a
safe haven for the black King anyhow
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below and as always I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you